-So dogs are the first
domesticated animal.
If you don't have domestication,
you don't have civilization.
And if we're interested in
the origins of civilization,
you got to know where those dogs
came from in the first place.
So we know that dogs were
domesticated from grey wolves.
Nobody doubts that for a second.
There are a range of
other competing hypotheses
about when and where
dogs were domesticated.
And what we also know is that
all modern dogs group together
to the exclusion of
all modern wolves.
So we don't know which
population of wolves
really gave rise to those dogs.
And so the hunt is
now on to try and find
that original wolf
population that
gave rise to all modern dogs.
What really excites
me about this project,
is that we're able to take
advantage of the revolution
in sequencing technology.
And we're going to be
generating hundreds of thousands
of base pairs extracted from the
bones and teeth of ancient dogs
and wolves.
And that's going to
allow us to really get
to grips with the genetic
differences between dog
and wolf populations
through time,
and that's going to be able
to tell us which populations
were those that were involved
in the original domestication.
So our mission is to collect
several thousand samples
from all over the world,
spanning the last 30,000 years.
And we're going to
combine a genomic approach
with a morphological
approach, which
will allow us to
really get to grips
with the process of
domestication itself.
We're going to be able
to use what's called,
geometric morphometrics.
It's about the
resolution of material,
but it's also really
about this discriminating
between size and shape.
And that means, if we
can look at shape alone,
where we're not going to
be influenced by size,
then the shape allows us to
get to grips with the process
of domestication,
what's happening
to the organism,
to what populations, too,
and what changes are really
bringing them along a
trajectory toward becoming dogs.
The only reason a project
of this scale works
is because of its massive
international collaboration.
And we are relying very much
on the generosity and expertise
of a wide range of
scientists and museums
who are not only
providing material
and a great deal of
knowledge, but are also
giving us perspective on
trying to really think
about this problem through a
huge amount of space and time.
And their specific
expertises are really
allowing us to try and
piece it all into one
very large picture, rather than
relying on very small subset
of material at any one time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]